previously on TV sins took the watch off
an old coffee can and in that can it
stayed YouTube comments section the TV
ship also who's the redhead arguing with
on the other side of the table it was
anyone arguing with dogs playing poker I
check raise listen [ __ ] the spirit
just said check so you're not raising
any fun thing has to be a bet in order
for you to then raise sure is a good
thing poker exists or how else would we
know when a character is so much smarter
than everyone else also man what an
amazing card player heard he is he's got
pocket aces and hit a set and the other
guy just has pocket queens and he hit a
set with no flutter straights possible
it's just so insane what a good player
Harvey is to get all the money on that
hand you have to be so good to get all
the money in that situation blackberry
so I'd say the balls in your court
for the truth is your balls are in my
fists finally legal show where it's all
about men being men and swinging their
round to see whose is bigger prior to
this we only have Perry Mason la la
bonne order jag murder one practice
Boston Legal and the defenders to whet
our appetite but I'm sure suits will be
the one that differentiates itself right
good thing this human missed setting a
booklet on a table at point-blank range
or else how would we know how clever and
cunning our protagonist was what is he
anything I said I was gonna get you 158
I got my money please shouldn't cheater
McGee wait and see if he actually got
the 158 before paying Mike also this is
insinuating that he cheated the L set by
using this guy's ID to problems he looks
nothing like this guy and since the test
administrator recognized him at the end
shouldn't you freak nasty while checking
him in as well
props Department is like how do we
convey a reckless rich a crotch rocket
yes but one in the living room but they
don't live on the ground floor exactly
you want in you aren't in you know is
word for words your offer before I got
caught cheating on your math test in the
third grade what the hell is a
nine-year-old offering someone to get in
on in the third grade secret underground
Pokemon trade card ring I mean look at
me this is a $2,000 suit Mike damn it
you were one s away from rolling
commercials yeah one job Trevor
safe it is I'm trying to get him to work
for me that's a great idea we'll take
some stress off Trevor and you'll pick
up writing code like you do everything
else writing code sounds like Jenny
might catch Trevor and some pretty
little lies soon how did you know Gerald
would look at that memo cuz a charging
bull always looks at the red cape not at
the man with the sword when you really
think through this metaphor wouldn't the
fake document be the red cape which
means Gerald would have been looking
directly at it and caught Harvey in
Islam and is it the sword - I'm not sure
this metaphor makes sense attorney I
close situations say you only care about
money
I waited tables for a while I must have
been doing so many things wrong because
when I came to the table I asked if
their food was ok and avoided assumptive
insults they say I don't normally do
this but since we are celebrating what
time do you get off tonight
glad you asked I get off at 10 past I'm
never going out with you I almost want
to take a sin off for that not working
but it was a really bad comeback line
and it actually ends up working so 23%
of this over long pilot is establishing
shop Metro porn 15 seconds of this guy
deciding to stay in bed is 15 seconds
too long because when you put two
bullies in the same room together things
generally don't go so well is this
supposed to be funny because Harvey is a
bully he bullied his client and he's
bullying his associate with your wife
jokes
Harvey is saying things that sound smart
but really don't have any substance when
you try and take a bite Harvey is a
croissant I see that you're also trying
to look like a pimp what makes this suit
pimp e're than this one the shininess
the incredibly tight tailoring that
gives Harvey a flattering figure this is
the suit your wife picked out for me and
that would be funny if I'd actually be
married humor is subjective this is my
channel then I'm saying the fact that
this guy doesn't have a wife made that
funnier all Senior Partners get an
associate it's just a rule I'm sorry
what yeah and with the grumpy co-worker
cliche guy here you choose this moment
to convey that information I'm sorry I'm
still stuck on the pimp suit comment is
it the striped shirt and the stripe tire
that makes it pin T six buttons on his
vest I bet it's the two coat pockets I
just don't want to be mislabeled as a
pimp luckily for me all my suits are
from a discount store so if anyone
confuses me for a pimp I'll say ah I'm
not that kind of [ __ ] and second
these suit pockets aren't even real
let's talk about Harvey's real talent as
a button ninja never figured out how to
button my coat without touching the
buttons honestly this is the first time
I've been impressed with Harvey so far
I'm in one-time deal cool we're throwing
in a little
that one last job energy that all the
great productions are always going on
about should make this episode feel
super fresh for the record I cannot take
anyone seriously when they hold this
type of pet when it's ours we'll know if
there's new buyers it comes and I'm
saying it this loudly directly after the
guy I'm hiding that info from left the
room because I'm in a TV show that
doesn't think about how real humans keep
secrets he said these guys are cops
whoever's holding that weed is going to
jail for a long time I've seen enough
episodes of Matlock to know that if Mike
just gives up Trevor then Trevor just
gives up this guy then they'll figure
out the score and wife shot her
husband's lover and what was I talking
about again my mom's coming by my place
later I don't want to mess it up so hang
in here horrible habit does she have
that in order to avoid doing it in her
own home she has to hide at her
boyfriend's house context clues tell us
it's a messy habit or hobby I'm going
with indoor beekeeping possible love
interest fixes Thai because the guy
can't do it properly cliche how did you
know I was your successor a gun Jesus
alias episode took forever to get
started almost all that's the lawyer and
the dude taking the bar exam for money I
sure hope they start talking about
Rambaldi soon because I need my fix so
what you gonna do about it how would you
do about it
the man's missing compassion yeah shut
down his throat 20 minutes in and this
show has a lot of what he dialogue I'm
pretty sure no one has actually said a
goddamn thing that makes sense
[Music]
plot reasons kid and you are the one
that has to suffer for it
can I help you no this officer had
absolutely zero clue whether Mike went
up or down the stairs
what floor he got off on or what
direction he would then go somehow finds
his way to the exact place Mike actually
ended up before a magic is this my name
is Louis litt Louis litt I think I've
heard of your brother Mike seem to
remember they used to get calls for him
at this animated bar at when I'm in
Springfield and you not only did not go
to her law school you haven't even
gotten to any law school what if I told
you that I consume knowledge like no one
you've ever met and I've actually passed
the bar considering this show could have
easily been titled this works I feel
like I should just tack on an extra 20
cents here for its entirety also this
show has the weirdest setup and plot
since my mother the car but you're
sitting at a computer playing hearts
sorry if you want to be me you're gonna
have to do it as something else okay
fine these two are actually really good
together
I'd watch them try to one-up each other
forever except I well because I haven't
even started on Tribble yet so I was
sent off for a Mike and Harvey's
chemistry but then put it right back on
for this stupid peak TV era one of the
things did not like the other number
seven missed the dark suit memo that day
that our Mitchell will make a convenient
plot appearance later Euler he does
Clifford Watkins whatever Clifford was
blabbering on about was so dis
interesting that this woman can't be
bothered to stick around for the
punchline she instantly runs for it this
ever happens to you in a conversation
it's a clear sign that you're an [ __ ]
so if you subtly hand me your nametag
you can proceed directly to the dean's
office this idea is fun and all but
wouldn't Clifford get to the office
realize he'd been bamboozled alert the
staff and reconnect with the tour in 20
minutes
hi good morning after seat I've never
understood these interactions normal
people wait for the receptionist to
finish the phone call before talking or
maybe my mom it just raised me right
Jesus this firm is amazing they have the
duchess of sussex as a researcher you
know nobody likes nobody likes a
show-off this is true also showing off
is approximately three thousand two
hundred sixty seven percent of what this
show is comprised of I just got reamed
for lying to a client and if they find
out that I lied about you going to
Harvard they'll take away my license
they would have done that regardless of
the first law I got myself a job as a
secretary at Tesla regret hey you mean
the drug company in the fugitive that
may profess Akande killed a guy who
found out it caused liver damage that
company I know this story is important
at all but she really needs to stick a
bookmark in that book or the wind is
gonna blow the pages she'll lose her
place at Kaos not about caring of about
winning why can't you be about both
because then this show would be about
genuinely nice people and that is not in
the USA Network's agenda then what do
you need my help for I don't know how to
fill out a subpoena really you can Rain
Man chapter and verse from the bar exam
but you can't do a quick Google search
on how to fill out some paperwork
these joke setups are as paper thin as
the subpoenas they're based around okay
I have two words for you if you
compliment her right now the two words
should be sexual harassment absolutely
beautiful
dumbass what are you doing here what any
drug dealer does when someone runs off
with a briefcase of Pop rajat Sports
Center oh well okay then Harvey what a
coincidence is it though considering you
work at the same building and see each
other all the damn time you would think
that he would use discretion when
handing over a stack of cash for sex
pics but no he proudly reuses that
window down Volokh the utility company
sent him Harvey the environmentalists
will sleep better tonight knowing he did
his part to save the earth
get this banana gentlemen really guess
I've been watching a different show for
the last 50 minutes who does this before
entering a store unless they want to
look like a crazy person
now shall we play I'm not gonna let you
win Harvey play is a set of tennis in a
suit as well the show is taking its name
very seriously
I think hunt did the same thing to her
that he did to me you said he's a thin
what no what the hell is wrong with you
I need the briefcase back considering he
didn't think to open a goddamn pizza box
even though he thought to open the oven
I'm thinking Trevor doesn't deserve to
get the briefcase back holy Sh not
expecting a whole bunch of monsters
including a giant snake to come out of
these elevators any second you plant a
fake employee to manipulate the
associate that's it lawyer thinks he's
lost the case but has an aha moment from
an arbitrary conversation about
something that has nothing to do with
the case cliche let's admit I look very
dashing here we are at his bachelor
party
Harvey points to this picture when he's
talking about how dashing he looks but
he's pointing at the same picture when
he talks about the bachelor party and
Nancy gets reinstated with backpack oh
happy day you now get to go to work for
the very [ __ ] who fired you for not
him what a wind didn't smile I was
thinking of a funny joke I bet it
involves lawyers in a bar and probably
something homophobic and/or racist
from a suit let's go a few rounds right
I got off at 10 past I'm never going out
with you
I guess so you're not the best closer
this is everything you went to Harvard
Law wait like it's hard steve-o a tongue
stir making copies mr. Tom I've enjoyed
myself since 2004 kill anybody
1984 and I made myself clear crystal I'm
sorry we don't sell skinny jeans at this
location big mistake big huge I'm not an
idiot don't treat me like one
we tried pulmonary stimulators and and
cardiac infusing infusers